today in an economy that's marked with
technological change and globalization
and heightened competition and
uncertainty companies recognize that
they really need to be adaptive in order
to successfully adapt their
organizations they need to be able to
recruit manage and retain people who
themselves are adaptive people who
themselves are entrepreneurial able to
take risk really what organizations do
to attract these sorts of
entrepreneurial people is they deliver a
value proposition that resonates with
ambitious talent and the way we distill
that value proposition is in the word
transformation amazing ambitious
talented entrepreneurial employees seek
the opportunity to transform themselves
their organization in the world at large
they want to know that by working at
your company they will have the
opportunity to acquire skills develop
unique experiences grow their network
and in general make their LinkedIn
profile look more impressive they want
to be on the winning teams within the
company and they want to know that
they're not just going to be shuffling
papers but really have the opportunity
to transform the company directory in
the modern world lifetime employment
sover it's just not the case that great
people want to spend 50 straight years
working for the same organization and
it's highly unlikely that the same
organization will need that particular
type of person in that particular
personality and skill set for the rest
of time far better to be open and honest
on day one far better to have what we
call an alliance conversation more by
the manager sits down with the employee
and says what I do want you to do is to
be able to commit to me sort of ethic ly
that you'll stick around for a
meaningful period of time what we call a
tour of duty and do real work at this
organization that helps transform the
company and as your ally I will make
sure that over the course of that tour
of duty I will invest in you and that by
you staying for that meaningful but
realistic period of time you will
experience career growth you will
develop skills that matter in the market
you will grow your network and that's
what the Alliance is all about mutual
investment and you
you'll benefit both sides get ahead if
both sides can trust each other enough
to invest in each other for a realistic
period of time that's how you maximize
employee engagement and at the end of
the tour of duty maybe it makes sense
for the employee to leave the company
and move on or maybe it makes sense for
the employee to do another tour of duty
and so I think that's what the modern
dynamic around employee engagement and
retention looks like its realism but
it's with an emphasis on an alliance and
mutual benefit in order to effectively
engage and retain great people for
realistic periods of time